In this lesson, we will learn how to write control programs to customize network
control. We will review the operation of a hub and a learning switch, then
we will explore how to use the POX controller to create a simple MiniNet
topology. And then we will explore how
to customize the Pox controller to perform two
types of network control. As a review, when a host sends a
packet to a hub, the hub maintains no state About which output port a package
should be forwarded to reach a
particular destination. Therefore, the hub simply forwards
the input package on every output port. In Pox, this code is fairly simple.
When the controller starts. It adds a listener that listens for a connection up,
which is a connection from a switch. When switch connects, it simply sense
and open-flow, flow modification back to the
switch it says flood all packets out
every output port. The first function here
involved creates the open-flow massage. And the
second sends that message back to the
switch. In contrast a learning switch maintains
a switch table that's initially empty. But when a packet arrives on input port
1, the switch creates a table. That associates host A with output port 1,
such that whenever a subsequent packet is
destined for destination A, the switch knows
to forward the packet via output port 1. I won't show you the full Python
code here. But it's fairly simple, and you can go look at the Pox distribution
to see the learning switch example. As
before, when the first packet arrives at the
switch, it is diverted to the controller, at
this point, the controller maintains a hash table
that maps the address to the out put port, when it sees that first packet
>From Post A, it updates the address and
port table. If the packet's a multicast packet,the
controller makes a decision to flood that
packet on all output ports. Likewise, if there's
no table entry for the destination for that
packet, the controller also instructs the switch to
forward the packet on all output ports.
If the source and destination address are the
same, The controller instructs the switch to
drop the packet. Otherwise, the controller installs the
flow table entry corresponding to that destination
address and output port. Installing that flow table
entry in the switch prevents future packets for
that flow from being redirected to the controller.
Rather, all subsequent packets on that flow
can be handled directly by the switch,
since it now knows which output port
to send a packet for that particular destination.